الى فرنسا حيث يواصلوا اعضاء النقابات
قطاع النقل الحضري في باريس الكبرى
اضرابهم لليوم الثاني على التوالي
للمطالبه برفع الاجور ياتي الاضراب بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع من اضراب ان شاء الله حركه
النقل بالسكك الحديديه ومن امام احدى
محطات النقل في باريس ينضم الينا مراسلنا
نور الدين بوزيان نور الدين اذا اضرابات
سابقه حاليا ومرتقبه كذلك كيف تنعكس على
حياه
الفرنسيين والمسافرين وكيف تتعامل معها
السلطات كذلك
وسيله بالنسبه للاضراب الذي لم يبقى منه
سوى بعض الساعات اذ ينتهي من المقرر غدا
السبت الساعه السابعه صباحا يمكن القول
بانه لم يؤثر على حركه ونشاط
الفرنسيين وتحديدا السكان باريس
الكبرى بحيث
لاحظنا بان فقط بعض الباصات تاخرت اليوم
عن مواعيد نشاطها واما المترو كما تشاهدين
خلفي وسلاف الحركه عاديه وهمم في الحقيقه
يمكن ارجاع ذلك لكون ربما ان احدى اثتين
من النقابات المهمه لم تلتحق باذراب اليوم
والاداره نفسها اداره النقل الحضري هنا في
باريس الكبرى قالت بان تاثير لم يكن
تاثيرا كبيرا واعترفت بان الحركه فقط
اقتربت فيما يتعلق بالنقل همم عبر الباصات
بالنسبه للاضرابات في الحقيقه وحركه الغيا
الغليان المجتمعي في فرنسا يمكن القول
وسيله بان فرنسا تحبس انفاسها في انتظار
يوم الخميس القادم حيث اجمعت النقابات على
شان اضراب وصفاته بانه سيكون شديدا وتحدثت
عن اضرابات ومظاهرات وتتخوف الان الحكومه
من اي يؤدي ذلك الى شل الحركه في فرنسا
مثل ما حدث في السنوات القليله الماضيه كل
ذلك بسبب رفض النقابات وايضا الكثير من
الفرنسيين لمشروع قانون الحكومه
بضروره تعديل وتغيير نظام التقاعد طبعا
يجب ان نتوقف عند مساله اخرى مهمه وهي ان
المفاوضات التي بداتها النقابه التي دعت
الى الاضراب لمده يومين الان بدات ولا
يعرف ما اذا كانت الاداره او ممثله
الحكومه في هذه المفاوضات ستقبل بالشروط
الجديده للكونفدراليه العامه للشغل كل ما
هو مؤكد بان النقابات قررت تشن اضراب يوم
الخميس هددت اهم نقابه في قطاع تكرير
النفط بانها ستنظم ثلاثه ايام ولكن ليس في
يوم واحد او ايام متتاليه وانما على فترات
اضراب ربما سيعيد الى الاذهان وخاصه هواجس
الفرنسيين من ان تتعطل الحركه تماما ايضا
في محطات الوقود وتذكرين جيدا ماذا حدث في
بدايه الخريف الماضي عندما اضربت بعض
النقابات في منشات تكرير ان يمكن القول
اذا بان رهان القوه بين النقابات بين
الشارع الفرنسي والحكومه قد بدا اليوم